you
coming live from the back of the church
welcome to the table happy new year thank you thanks shiloh it's 2023 y'all we we made it
and while i know the turn of the calendar is not always like necessarily oh it's new life for me
sometimes you're waking up to the exact same problems you went to sleep to or the same job
or the same whatever and so i realize that it's not always a big celebration the turning of the
calendar but i do appreciate the collective nod across the world that we are all turning
the calendar together and we all survived that year together there's some bit of camaraderie
in it that i think is really beautiful and so i think a collective nod to that as we all sit
in this room you chose here to be chose to be here tonight on new year's day and i think that
says a lot about you and a lot about our church it's a great a great place to find yourself
so if you'll join me by closing your eyes take a deep breath in through your nose and you're
going to go out through your mouth in through your nose out through your mouth
let's do one more together
and as you exhale i want you just to say under your breath i made it
you made it open your eyes join me in the here and now it's a big deal it's a big deal to have
made it with all that the world throws at us all the different mental health issues um it's a big
deal that you're here tonight so thank you thank you for making it i'm so glad you're here um next
sunday we are going to have a baptism sunday so it's going to be a really special treat if you're
interested in that um and getting baptized you can fill out a card on your way out um we would
love to be a part of that and that'd be a part of your story here and then tonight the first sunday
of every month we have a family dinner at hat creek which is kind of like a chick-fil-a but
it's open on sundays so it's not but there's an outdoor playground so it's really family friendly
so if you'd like to join us there tonight we would love we would absolutely love that
tonight is also a very special night it's our story sunday which is my absolute
favorite sunday of the year where we will have two people from our table um share their stories
about who they are why they're here how they got here and with such a eclectic community as this
these stories are fascinating you're going to want it to never end you're going to hope there's
a follow-up podcast continuing the story because you people are amazing and so bizarre and i love it
so i'm glad you're here this is a real treat
this is a real treat
yes it is i wasn't ready i'm sorry i was still highlighting some notes
all right will you guys stand with us we are going to kick off with some worship
um yeah he makes all things new and um this year i hope that as we're as we're joining each sunday
night as we're coming together and sharing this space i hope that in these times of music
there's some creativity that stirs up inside of you that gives you hope that there is
newness there is new life in him so um let's sing uh with whole hearts with hopeful hearts tonight
you broke my chains of sin and shame and you covered me with grace
you meant my life with your holy fire you cover me with grace
you are the hand that reaches out to say i am set free
oh
free you broke my chains of sin and shame and you covered me with grace
you meant my life with your holy fire you cover me with grace
you are the hand that reaches out to say i am set free
i am set free
it is for freedom
that i am set free
oh
me
yes lord we are grateful for your grace and for your love
oh
i am set free
oh i am set free
it is for freedom that i am set free
free
we're set free free
all right you kiddos are dismissed to your classrooms
i think they want you to go through these front doors up here judah j all right okay
and we're going to um enter into the prayers of the people so uh if you're with us tonight for
the first time um we're going to read this all aloud together and then there will be space for
you to share a name or a situation that's weighing heavy on your heart tonight and um just in
solidarity as a community we want to carry each other's burdens and we also want to trust that
god is carrying them with us that he sees us and um he knows us best um so we want to just
go together in this space and if you're online you can meet those economists and then we'll all
with the prayer at the end
for the city of saxony and for every city and community and all who live in it
we pray to you for the good earth that you have given us and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you for the old and the sick for the widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor and the oppressed the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and all who remember and care for them we pray to you for the vulnerable
the marginalized and those unjustly targeted for their gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those experiencing loss loneliness and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional health we pray to you lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us so we lift these names and situations up to you
jewel burgess
chelsea and jennifer
for the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we've kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life and light healing and hope peace and a deep sense of your presence amen
we've been hiding in the shadows lost and afraid of you
we've been wandering in the darkness but if we only knew
you
we are known and loved by you
so
you've been waiting to show us mercy your presence is our home
we're your children love forever now everything is gone
we are
we are known and loved by you
we are known and loved we are known and loved by you
there is no fear anymore
oh
because all that's left is mercy there is no fear
in your love because you're the god of mercy there is no fear
there is no fear anymore
that's all that's left is mercy there is no fear
in your love in your love
love
we are known and loved by you
yes we are known and loved known and loved we are known and loved by you
oh
sweet to trust in jesus just to take him at his word just to rest upon his promise
and to know the sith
sing jesus jesus jesus how i trust him how i proved him
more and more jesus jesus precious jesus oh for grace to trust him more
oh
i'm so glad i learned to trust the precious jesus savior friend
and and i know that thou are with me will be with me to the end
him
sing it together jesus jesus how i trust him how i proved him more and more
more jesus jesus precious jesus oh for grace to trust him more
oh
jesus jesus how i trust him how i proved him more and more
jesus jesus precious jesus oh for grace to trust him
jesus as we head into this next year would we learn to trust you
with things that we have been afraid to let go of in the past
god in the areas that i grasp for control would you help me to open my hands
knowing that you're a good god knowing that you are with us
knowing that you have come to provide light in our darkness
and hope in our hopelessness and healing in our pain
god would we look for that light
would we bring hope into situations
that need it most
would you strengthen our hearts would you give us courage
god would we find the light
we love you we thank you for another year we thank you for community
and sharing our stories together
god we are not forgotten by you
would we hold on to that would we remember it
as we walk through every high and low of this next year
would you be our anchor would you be our guide
would your love light the way in jesus name amen
amen would you guys turn to the people around you
all right some peace it is so good to be with you people it's uh new year's day anyone a little
tired i'm like seven o'clock person i mean i did it not for news i pushed her you know it's like
to go to sleep before midnight but um yeah so it's always you know next day for me it's like
all right it's a bit much um but it's it is it's so good to be with you all i'm so glad you're here
i didn't i didn't actually know if anyone would come so uh i'm like i'm delighted like you showed
up it's wonderful um and also i want to welcome those join us online we love you a lot so i'm
thinking of who else it's james is online with us um gail bayeron often who else seth horvath is
on there all the time james uh is on there all the time uh there's yeah a number of folks sorry
if i'm missing there's always the danger of listing specific people sorry um but i just want
y'all to know your you are uh loved too and um we're glad you're with us so um and also anyone
here who's um new in our midst thanks for for being with us it means a lot it can take a lot
of courage to walk through those doors come into a new space new community you know all that um
so tonight like kelly mentioned is it's a really special night and um i have no long sermon for you
because it is story sunday and um this is this is it's kind of this this practice that we've
been engaging for the last few years that we it's just i don't know there's something so
powerful about um letting people and giving space for people to just share vulnerably
about um just their story and sometimes it's focused on like the last year um sometimes
it's more of like over um you know decades which is kind of like tonight is some bigger picture
kind of longer term stories um but either way it's just it's always wonderful uh and honestly
you hear enough from me all year so i think i think we could all use a break um so it is
it's really great to hear from some other folks um we have a our text tonight is john 15 26 through
27 this is christ speaking he says when the advocate comes whom i will send to you from
the father the spirit of truth who goes out from the father he will testify about me and you also
must testify for you have been with me from the beginning and the key line there is that that
invitation for um for us to actually testify which is a little bit of a churchy word i know
but it just means to to um to share the story to name uh not only the goodness of god and the the
beauty of christ but even just to share like what um how christ has been active in our own lives
and there's just something so compelling and powerful about that so kind of my hope is that
uh that as you listen to these stories that like you start to see aspects of your own story
um kind of in and through even if the details you know of course will differ um but that there's
always like connection points and so um yeah be be just kind of having those those ears to hear
tonight to see what what god might be speaking to you in and through these folks so uh without
further ado our first person tonight our first story is going to be jeff pierceman y'all give
him a hand come on up friend let's see we centered you got it test test
i'm not good at this stuff
you're among friends right all right exactly yeah see look at them they look so nice they look so
nice so um jeff i really if y'all don't know jeff he's great what i really appreciate this will come
out more in his story is that uh like for where jeff is now it has been so hard fought like not
much came easy and uh and so just to see like the just the husband he is the follower of christ he
is like it's it's really it's it's wonderful so jeff how about you start just like kind of catch
us up for those who maybe don't know you share a little bit just about who you are you know now
and then take us back to like you know back to like family stuff and how yeah how how were you
raised and back to the day yeah way back in the day thank you um so yes i was born in uh the
netherlands in holland originally and uh my mom was uh there and of course and all that but uh
my my mom divorced and then married a traveling hippie as he came through in the 70s that was my
stepdad to be and uh then he wanted he he wanted to go back home so he says well why don't y'all
come with me so we all piled in and flew to america and here we are you wouldn't know it
unless i told you you know how old i was like five okay yeah yeah at the time yeah i'm still
a dutch citizen so you know you know you would never know absolutely um so we came here to the
states believe it or not we they bought a little uh one of them little volkswagen campers with the
pop-up tops and we traveled for about a year everywhere had flowers on the side you know all
that stuff you know you know the hippie thing whatever and uh we we settled in dallas to go
to christ for the nation's bible institute they found the lord or lord or the lord found them
and uh you know that's how we ended up here in dallas it was supposed to be for two years
i'm still here yeah um you know uh i think i was like eight to ten eight at that point and uh i
went to you know cfni and i went to trinity school you know trinity
so i was brought up from that point with god with christ and you know i was had the foundation there
i knew i knew what it was and i knew right from wrong for sure i just didn't care at some point
i think yeah yeah so uh yeah maybe it's that just didn't care is a good transition so eventually
uh your life it kind of took uh like a darker turn like a more difficult challenging um turn share
some of that that background and how you got there yep let me let me jump back real quick i forgot to
say that when we moved from there we we did eventually settle in in got in in got in garland
and my my mom and dad had four more kids besides me and my sister so there were six of us and they
all laid a pretty high quota to meet my brothers josh havens from the afters and uh they uh they
my sisters got a doctrine and they all got all this stuff so yeah and then there's me you know
so yeah i was the black sheep you could say yeah so kind of yeah what what happened or where
yeah where did things start to uh yeah so as a teenager i was pretty much lost i think we all
the traveling i was never able to lay down roots anywhere you know and i was just looking for an
escape or acceptance or you know anything that could you know just moving around and uh i was
doing drugs by the time i was 17 18 years old i was doing hard drugs and uh you know people always
say oh you did it because you're uh you had issues when you were younger or something to do with your
childhood well i don't believe any of that i did it because i liked it because you know i mean
that's the truth made you feel better yeah it made me feel better you know i never bought into all
that stuff so um and then uh so i was like 17 18 and i was i was still using i was you know you
start off with drinking and smoking and then you go from there to um you know other stuff and i'm
and and at some point i found meth and i really got stuck there for a very very long time and uh
or it found me whatever and uh um i did meth for for the next 10 years at least on a
monthly basis and i mean i managed to get a job and get a house and get married and get divorced
and you know have a kid and now i was had one foot in the drug world and one foot out in the
regular world but i was never able to escape it and uh at some at one point i managed to get a
uh i was on the road and and i i bought a new truck a semi-truck and i traveled you know
cross-country for 10 years moving furniture and uh i would pretty much use every time i came back
into town so my escape was to get out of town you know so get you know get out of town then i was
okay as long as i but then i come back in i said i'm never gonna do that again two months later
here i am you know and uh you i'm sure some of y'all know the routine but um yeah it's kind of
the the 10 years was that sort of back and forth or i guess was it gradually because you started
when you're 10 years was actually not the worst part that was the part leading up to the worst
part yeah it was you know i was still working and stuff but uh i was definitely an addict and uh
you always try to justify yourself whereas you look at other people that you know and you say
wow i'm not as bad as that guy so i'm okay you know until one day when you become that guy and
then everybody looks at you and they say oh i'm not as bad as jeff you know you you become the guy
that you said you weren't but uh it at um i think i think i was closer to 30 and i um around 30 i
ended up getting a dwi in garland i was in my vet and i made a u-turn in middle of the night and
that was it and i've been up for days and i've been you know always living on the edge and uh
that was the beginning of the end for me it was almost like god's
grace had fallen away and uh he was trying to tell me something and uh was this kind of like
your lowest like your lowest moment no not yet okay you're just on the way we're getting there
um yeah so i got the dwi i i it i ended up not working no more after that the next five years
was really rough i was an addict i was high for five years basically i'm to be honest i'll just
put it out there i there was maybe four or five days in there total that i wasn't
and uh that was it i mean i was just stuck and uh you know it took it took uh it took the police to
to get me to stop you know yeah so yeah what was the the kind of moment or was it a moment or was
it a little season where it was like okay not necessarily the turning point but at least a
moment of like wow like how did i get here and in that moment like i don't know what was that like
what was that like where did you feel a sense of like distance from god or was that like you
started to come closer to god or how did you experience it yeah you know they say that when
you go to jail uh you know everybody goes to god all of a sudden because that's all you got left
right but uh that was my low point and when i was sitting in jail and i was looking at out the
window and i was praying to god lord help me i'll change again you know and uh i said i'll i'll make
a difference i'll i'll do better send me a woman that that doesn't like to party all the time
because that's all i ever found you know and uh and well yeah he he did answer me so that's good
but uh it uh um it i was in there it's let me go back to this uh i was in jail and i was praying
to god to do something and it's funny how the lord works because he it's he i i seen a guy in there
and he went into rehab to like a christian rehab my you know by now i had already god wasn't you
know way in the back you know and i hadn't gone to church you know a long long time many years but
and and he went to a christian rehab and he went and he he went to court and he got out and a day
later they picked him up and he was gone to the ranch out in maybank texas in the middle of nowhere
in a great place and i was like wow that's cool i'm i'm ready to get out of here too i've been
in there two months i was like this sucks and uh so i called my my mama the lord led me to go to
christian rehab you know really it was just me manipulating the system still right but and uh i
just wanted out and because the other rehab which was court mandated you had to wait for six months
before you got to the six months you'd be in jail you'd be in jail for you and it was and it was
jail pretty much the rehab was also jail pretty much so anyway that was i the lord tricked me
and he said uh he said huh watch this so i made it work and sure enough i went to court and i was
two hours back and they picked me up you know and i'm on my way to maybank to a christian rehab
and uh going first you know for six months and but yeah i did definitely manipulate my way to
get there i thought it was you know the quickest way out yeah so was um i guess was this kind of
like a turning point kind of for you in your life or was it i thought it was and then it wasn't
um you know on my first visit back i ended up bringing back some drugs and that was you know
i still wanted to be the man and i wasn't and then and i got caught and everything you know
that's what happens in there but and then amazingly enough uh isaiah robertson he was
he used to be running back for the rams so he was the uh he's the owner back then bless his heart
he passed away but uh he says jeff i'm gonna uh you know i forgive you and let's move on
you know he didn't this is after you didn't kick me out okay yeah he didn't kick me out he says i
still love you it's we're gonna work it out you know so i'm still there so and then um that to me
was really like the turning point the next day i went to pastor bob and talked to him and told
him everything in my life and we prayed and cried and just we were there for hours and i just you
know and i walked out of the building that day a new man i was that's the day that i point to
and i said that made the difference for me right there because i've never looked back since then
yeah what just for context kind of what year or like roughly when when was that
that was uh that was a good 16 17 years ago okay probably yeah somewhere 16 18 years ago
somewhere right there yeah wow um so how about kind of like catch us up now so 16 years later
what's the journey been like what is your faith in christ mean now how's yeah how are you i'm good
i'm great uh i definitely believe that god still loves us he still loves me and and my family and
and i like to say i always say that i am living proof that no matter how deep you are in the
trenches that you can get out and still do great things you know you don't have to be there you
don't have to commit that that's who you are for life because that's what you've been into for so
long you you can do way better i got some of my my son's friends here and they're looking at me like
what in the world you know they wouldn't they didn't have a clue some of them but this this is
that's this is my past so it is what it is um i was laid down a uh a foundation for christ by my
parents and yeah i did i did escape from it i did get away from it and um but it was always there
that when i did get to jail that's what i was doing i was praying you know and i came back
so i hope that now at least i i have laid the foundation for my kids
so that they can if they stray they can always come back
wow it's beautiful beautiful jeff we're we're proud of you and we're we're glad that um you're
following christ and in a better a better place absolutely i'm glad to be here awesome well thank
you y'all give him a hand
all right next is my good friend marianna
all right so maybe a year or so i think not even i think we started like april-ish around easter
yeah yeah going on a year yeah one thing i i really appreciate about mariam is she has i don't
know if all of you got a chance to interact with her but she just has kind of a i don't know like
a certain joy or energy that when you're around her like it's just i don't know you just feel
better it's like that smile and everything's just like yeah i'm dying on the inside right now yeah
i'm like i'm so nervous no it's you're you're wonderful thank you so um give us a little bit
of a background a little bit like just like jeff kind of who you who you are you know now like where
you're living where you know and then take us back to like family upbringing and um some of that
that journey yeah definitely um i could talk for days on this so i'll try to condense it um
i am mariam i'm 29 i live up in anna texas with my bff right there uh so sorry so um used to be
a teacher i was a teacher for four years recently left that profession and now i'm working in
cyber security very similar not at all so i love it uh i am yeah that's where i am right now so
going back into my family history uh kind of like um what was that earlier you wouldn't know by
looking at me but i am half middle eastern i take after my mom my dad is palestinian
and so my dad grew up in uh in jordan and moved to america when he was in college and met my mom
and had seven of us and so my dad is muslim and had my mom convert to islam um so that they could
get married and so i was actually raised muslim um again seven children there were six girls and
one boy so kind of feel bad for my brother he's he's a sweet boy though um but we lived in houston
growing up and then moved down to corpus christi texas and so yeah lived my life um we were one of
not many muslim families there so there's a lot of like discrimination um just geared towards us
um because i did cover my hair um i did wear long sleeve and all that and now i'm up here with like
tattoos and everything so i did do all that practice the religion um and yeah it was pretty
rough um called names like terrorist all the time and just different things and so um my parents
separated and then divorced when i was 14 and the reason was because my mom left the religion
um so i was the only one of the seven kids that went and lived with my dad and so we kind of
hopped around went to an apartment went to houses and my dad uh remarried six months after
he divorced from my mom and i got two stepsisters out of that who were my age and uh that was great
uh and so went to college met my best friend sarah and that's gonna probably transition into
your next question so i'll leave it at that yeah so how i mean obviously now you're here
in a christian church yeah you know so how did some of that that kind of religious transition
like what did that look like yeah yeah definitely so i was very proud of my religion and i think i
was proud of it because um i tried to be that person that my dad wanted me to be um you know
stand firm in your faith you're going to be the one that turned out right out of all the kids and
so i wanted to make him proud um and so i had no intention of seeking out another religion um
actually on the flip side sarah was you know sharing christianity with me we met in college
we're in the same sorority and i was trying to convert her to islam and so i thought i was doing
a great job and look where we are today uh so i would bring my quran she would bring the bible
and honestly if you don't know they're very similar um the difference really happens at what
happened to jesus and onward but everything i believed in jesus growing up um and so we bonded
over that um and that process took three years three years of me going to church with her
i served in a church still covered um they let me come in much like this church we're
great about accepting anyone and everyone served in the church and throughout those three years
there was a lot of like signs i feel like from god and uh just things pointing me towards the
direction of christianity um and there was a big reason as to why i converted
i'm just gonna keep going you stop maybe you want me to stop um i'm gay and i've known since i was
very young and i hear the argument all the time oh you there's no way you could know that young
but my thing is is like at five years old you know kids have crushes and i'm like mine were
on girls and i i knew i knew my entire life but i was always told no no no it's a sin
uh abomination it's not okay and so a lot of the reason why i was uh so okay with leaving my faith
was because that faith was not taking the gay away and i was so desperate um countless nights
crying like what is wrong with me this is awful i'm going to hell blah blah blah and i saw sarah's
life change in christianity how she we we we were in a sorority we partied i mean we we did that and
then she was like oh i'm not gonna do this anymore i'm like wow your god changed you maybe he could
change me and so i was i was just i was desperate i knew i would lose my family but it was honestly
like i i couldn't i couldn't handle it anymore and so i converted to christianity when i was 20
and i did i lost part of my family i haven't talked to my dad in 10 years almost or he hasn't
talked to me um that whole side of my family and yeah i was just still desperate to pray it away
you hear that term pray the gay away and didn't work i i tried i we went on mission trips we've
been to multiple countries i served in ministry i devoted my life to trying to pray this away
but honestly like nobody knew it was all in secret because i didn't come out until last year
and i'm 29 now um so that was really really lonely um a very very lonely experience um
that was harder to deal with honestly than like losing my family um so that's kind of where i am
right now i know you have some follow-up questions that i forgot about so ask them and it'll come to
you well i'm i'm one thing i'm curious about is do you like thinking of these two kind of
major transition moments kind of based on what you just named are you saying that you think
probably that transition of coming out and accepting that part of yourself like that has
been a more challenging transition like was do you think that's that's been the more is that
kind of what i understood you yeah it has been because for me like becoming a christian was a
choice for me being gay is not a choice for me and it was easy for me to be like okay i'm making
this choice and i'm leaving my faith and going to this one but i have to accept being gay and
i'm not making this choice whether i want it or not it's here and so that's that's why it's been
harder for me some of that is kind of identity like the first is sort of i don't know this thing
that i can participate in or not or it's like a little bit more external somehow even though of
course our relationship with god is very personal but you know sort of like i'm going to participate
in this religious tradition or okay no now i'm going to do this one whereas like you said
sexual orientation that just it just gets so intertwined deeply with a sense of kind of who
we are and so that ended up being there was this um almost like a journey to accept
yourself yep is that i don't want to put words in your mouth but something like that absolutely and
it was a lot because i was i was told all the time that it was wrong and i honestly thought
something was wrong with me because i i couldn't get rid of it i couldn't um i i dated one person
and it was a guy and i was so desperate and he's he's one he's great he's one of my best friends
today um but i i was willing to be miserable and to make everyone else happy and honestly like
i realized that i didn't give enough credit to those around me because in my head i built up
these scenarios like oh they're going to ostracize me again i'm going to lose people again i don't
want this to happen again so i'm just going to live with it and i'll make everyone else happy
yeah what um what would you say to someone like maybe it's not even sexual orientation but
i think this is in a way just like jeff's journey is so applicable for anyone
struggling with like addiction or just parts of their life that feels kind of out of control and
i think for you it's like identity things like parts of myself that i'm struggling to
accept you know these things that i just want to change i got to change that and it's
but there's certain parts of us that we you know it's like our personality or so like it's
not changing um what would you say to them like whether it's a word of encouragement or
perspective or you know anything along those lines of if someone is um yeah struggling with
with that same kind of identity type type stuff yeah there's a few things a few words of
encouragement that i've heard so the first is there are things that we find hard to accept
within ourselves i mean everyone struggles with that what helped me was finding a community or
even close friends that i knew i could trust and one other thing was i was so scared to tell people
around me that i knew that i reached out to and i don't i'm not recommending this for everyone it
worked for me i reached out to people who experienced the same thing as me who were
gay women who came out that i didn't know people that i met um on social media and stuff and they
really encouraged me because i was reaching out to people who knew nothing about me they had no
prior judgment um i would encourage y'all to whoever is struggling with whatever really focus
in and hone on those people and give them credit they're in your life they love you they're gonna
love you no matter what and if not then they're not meant to be in your life and i've experienced
that time and time again thankfully coming out was an easier transition when it came to the people
around me um and i know not everyone has that experience but on the flip side if there is anyone
who knows somebody who's struggling with something i want to tell those people like we're not here to
try to change your conviction we kind of just wish that we were not judged for our own and that's the
biggest thing for us um and i would just encourage you to love on these people um again gay not gay
whatever they're struggling with love on them because if they're coming to you and they trust
in you that that that's a big step so i would encourage them with that yeah it's wonderful
mariam your story is um it's really it's pretty remarkable remarkable and i appreciate your
courage and in sharing with with all of us so yeah absolutely thank you y'all give her a hand
all right
all right um
that was a wonderful one
give them one more hand it's really great
it is it's always just fascinating to like i don't know just pull back the layers of someone
you know get to know them it's uh it's always surprising and i think it's it's interesting how
it's it's strange or maybe yeah not interesting i'll say it's strange how we can so often come
in here and sit in these seats and feel so alone you know like in our struggles in our journey
like no one else has you know i mean and it's like that gets in our heads and it isolates us
from people this is why one one of our values here at the table is um being vulnerable vulnerability
because there is there's just something about folks as we open up we start to realize like
i'm not alone i mean everyone is on their journey everyone is imperfect struggling going through
tremendous challenges uh not feeling like oh yes my life's all together and that that's yeah it's
so i hope you you were encouraged um and hearing them share so so honestly and vulnerably so we're
going to transition to to communion now and um this is the way i kind of want to frame tonight
as we come forward to participate is that we've heard some stories tonight and each of us we have
our own but to be christian is not to just like make up our story or to pretend that we don't
have one uh but it's to embrace the story that christ has given us and to recognize that god is
present to us in the midst of it like it's it's not um just us on our own but we're here a part
of a community i mean even to to come forward and partake of the bread which is represents the body
of christ and um which represents his blood like even to do that is to participate in this broader
story and so i i hope there's just a sense of um being caught up in something bigger than yourself
that then starts to orient you and make sense of your own story uh this is something i'll probably
get into in a few weeks um more of how we really are this culture is very um the more secular parts
of it it's like the story lists people the people who have no story but as we come to participate
in this we don't come as the story list people but as the storied people so come as as you are
as yourself with your story and know god god meets you in the midst of it so we practice what's called
an open table meaning if you're here tonight and you want to participate then you are free to do
that we're um basically just what needs to be present is some desire in you to connect with
christ if you're like i don't know how all of this works but christ i trust that you're there
somehow and i want to know you you know like if that's just this is as simple of a prayer as it is
uh you're you're welcome pate to participate with us and um also one other thing to know is we are
transitioning to real wine after many a year of saying come partake of the wine but it's always
grape juice we are actually going to have wine now having said that if you're in a place where
you're like oh i don't know about actual wine um there is right in the center are some
uh clear cups and that is uh grape juice so if that's that's you then that's that's perfectly
fine um but we're we're just getting a little more traditional around here
so um the way you'll come forward is we'll form two lines and you can just kind of you know go
off to the to the sides and partake the instructions will be be on the screen so this is the table
not of the church but of the lord and it's made ready for those who love him and for those who
want so come you who have much faith and you who have little you who have been here often and you
who have not been here long you who have tried to follow and you who have failed come because it's
the lord jesus who invites you and it's his will that those who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
so
uh
wow
so
so if you guys are finished partaking if you'd like to stand and sing this last song with us
um i like the idea of starting this first day of the year as this
sort of prayer that we can all sing together just um with the hopes that we will
go with God and include Him in every part of our life
so
let's arise strength of God
as I wait eyes of God look upon be my side
so
as I hear heart of God
I satisfy and sustain as I hear voice of God lead me on be my guide be my guide
I above and below me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me
above and below me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me
my side as I rest breath of God fall upon bring me peace bring me peace
above and below me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me above
and below me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me
is
Christ be all around me
your life your death your blood was shed for every moment every moment your life your death
your blood was shed for every moment every moment your life your death your blood was shed
for every moment every moment your life your death your blood was shed for every moment every moment
above and below me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me
Christ be all around me
Mindy worship team thank you all so much um y'all I just think we should pause for a second and give
this woman a round of applause as our worship leader she's amazing it's amazing the songs that
she picks out pair with Brett's sermon they're intentionally the the lyrics are pairing with what
is being shared and I don't think it takes a you know a literature major to notice that
not a brain surge usually people say brain surge anyways um it's amazing and so she does this
day in day out weekend week out and it's thank you Mindy it's a gift thank you um I want to clarify
earlier I said in the people sharing their stories at the table I love them because they're bizarre
and I want to clarify that the word bizarre is a compliment I looked up the definition
just to double like make sure I was like oh gosh it means odd and peculiar and one of our words
that is the the pillar of the table is eclectic you can't be eclectic if we're not a little
peculiar and odd and I think Jesus was odd so that was a compliment and I just wanted to clarify
thank you all for being here um at the end of the service I will be at the back if you want
to pray together if you want a hug or a high five I would love to just lift you up or hear what you
are hurting about what you're worried about as the year unfolds um I will be back there
right after service if you'd like to join us at Hat Creek we would love to have you it's the
first Sunday of every month is where we'll be hanging out there after church next Sunday is
Baptism Sunday if you're interested in that you can fill out a card on your way out um also join
us for more depth of stories of people's stories unfolding and how they really connect us all I
loved what Miriam said about the Quran and the Bible really aren't that different and actually
you when you think they're so different you actually sit down and realize oh we're the same
kind of different and in that difference you're the same and there's real beauty in that there's a
profoundness in that and I I think that's true for all of us but you don't know that if you don't
share that your story with one another so joining a meetup group continuing to come to this community
that wants you here and needs you here and needs your story because the more odd the more stories
the more we can spread love and healing to desperate places that need that so thank you all
for sharing your stories and I encourage you to keep showing up and keep sharing your story
um I have a benediction which is just a prayer for the road a prayer for the year ahead
so if you want to take a posture of sitting down and closing your eyes or opening your hands and
closing your eyes or just staring ahead and listening I just want to speak this over you
and you can absorb it however you may need as the next 365 days unfold may these truths
be yours may these truths be guideposts as you navigate the highs and lows that are sure to come
may you wake up every day knowing you are a precious child of God you are worthy of being
known and loved may you be brave enough to share your struggles and ask for help may you have
strength and compassion to join others in their own trenches may vulnerability like that give you
community that loves you like Jesus may the only striving you do this year be to love God
and love others to love God and love others and may you love you you are a child of God
you are precious you are known you are loved you are one to come here at this table of Jesus
God shine your light upon us lead us draw us closer together and closer to you
in Jesus precious name amen see you at Hat Creek
before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me above and below
me before and behind me in every eye that sees me Christ be all around me
Christ be all around me
oh Christ be all around me